hi there Steve Kaufman today I want to
talk about words the importance of words
and how many words we need it's a
subject that comes up regularly I came
across a very interesting article and in
fact I'm going to write a blog post
about it it might have it up next week
after started writing it we need lots of
words essentially in order to learn a
language beyond the sort of very
superficial social level we need a large
vocabulary the best way to acquire that
vocabulary in my opinion is through a
lot of reading and reading things that
are meaningful and in fact historically
that's how people learned languages and
what we discover when we start reading
things that are interesting to us not
just textbook material in fact you need
a lot of words and the vast majority of
language courses don't enable the
learner to acquire a sufficient
vocabulary to go out and read a book and
I believe that in any of the languages
that I have learned I want to get to
where i can read books of interest to me
history literature whatever it might be
that I can without difficulty and
enjoyably read things that interest me
to do that you need a lot of words and
there is this myth about that if you
have a thousand words you can cover just
about any context in the language it's
simply not true apparently according to
research 100 to 150 words will probably
cover in most languages up to fifty
percent of the words in any given
context however once you get beyond that
the words are less and less frequent in
fact the less and less frequent words
appear very much less frequently and so
the example was given in James Joyce's
Alyss seas for example which apparently
has a total words of about 250,000 but
uses 30,000 different words so you
in order to understand every word in
Ulysses you would have to know 30,000
words now research has shown that as
long as you have about ninety eight
percent of the vocabulary in any given
text or book you can read it quite
comfortably I mean unless you're working
on the internet with access to a an
online dictionary you're using it and
Link As I do for most of my language
learning where I can cope with texts
that have to say twenty percent on the
Lord's because I'm saving them in them
I'm going to encounter them again and
the whole process is helping me learn
them but I want to get to where I can
just pick up pick a book off the
bookshelf and read it and for that I
need to have 95 ninety-eight percent
coverage now it's been shown that in
many many books words that only appear
once twice or three times in the text
may account for thirty to fifty percent
of the words in that text so you're
going to be meeting a lot of rare words
so the unfortunate in a sense collateral
is it calling and I forgot the Kirk
corollary of the fact that high
frequency words account for a high
percentage of any text is that you need
a lot of low frequency words in order to
make sense of the text and since reading
is so important to building up our
fluency and our ability to understand
and especially if you combine it with
listening therefore a focus on
vocabulary and comprehension is much
more important than the traditional
approach of teaching people some grammar
and a few basic words and hoping that
they can somehow make it in real
situations they can't thank you for
listening went on a bit long today